Then, and then, man, our ancestor, try to settle down peacefully.
But according to the documents we have of those times,
organization and foresight were not his dominant characteristics.
In a hundred years, the population of the Earth has more than doubled,
and the balance between man and nature seems to be threatened.
What a pleasure to find peace and quiet at home.
Hey, Mr. I caught that one, you get me?
Sure, I was just joking.
It's not bad, huh?
Come see the Sputnik, the very first satellite in outer space.
During these same years, urbanism is born, and all the happy consequences are soon to manifest themselves throughout the world.
Thank goodness in your home you're safe from all that, huh?
What's this world coming to, my children? I can't see any end to all of it.
Fuse, rushed, crowded, and rushed some more.
We better hurry. You better hurry. They better hurry.
Trees produce. Yes, we produce. And you produce. And they produce.
Consumer goods will be marketed.
There must be a way to educate, create consumers, spenders, by the tens, by the millions, by the tens of millions that the factories produce.
A steak.
We'll see how long they'll last.
Incredible event.
Here's the very first man out in space, Yuri Gagarin.
Now time passes. Four years after the first man out in space, we see a man walk in space, Alexis Leonov. So man has taken a giant step in.
Where can we go to escape this breakneck rhythm? The crowds. I.S. Navy.
Vision. We have a liftoff. And now we can walk on the moon. Well now, what a world we live in, my children.
1970, medical science had evolved, and the world population grew at an alarming rate.
For the first time, it was to double every 35 years.
A symposium of economists, scientists, and futurologists sound the alarm.
A halt has to be made to our growth or the Earth will be in serious trouble.
Its resources are limited and it cannot sustain this growth indefinitely.
But who listened to these men and women of vision?
Three billion souls were dying of hunger in affluent countries.
And the Rhine each day spills out 60 million tons of waste into the North Sea.
That's equal to one ton per person in the area.
And the factories go on producing.
These are the finer things of civilization.
that warms you way it pretty to keep our food from getting cold that we're getting models for
the afternoon for the evening stuff it's no good at all my friend we can't do much with all those
idiotic things the question to swim here i think it's time that we did something think their voice
will be heard here industry spews into our seas two million three hundred thousand metric tons
of lead one million six hundred thousand metric tons of manganese six million five hundred thousand
tons of phosphorus and mercury cadmium and other poisons for too long now man has believed that the
sea could absorb everything missiles and missile anti-missiles they won't get away with this and
because now we're the strongest weapons are going to be thrown out now time to work guys gotta clean
all this up recently everything in nature was decomposable permitting the cycle of life to
continue in harmony but that's no longer true and the volume of garbage multiplies by 10 each decade
To avoid being completely submerged, the cities grew straight up.
This war has been declared on garbage.
Can we blame it on our ancestors who knew five centuries ago that the Earth was round
and therefore its resources were limited?
Are encircled by the order routes, by the bridges,
by the factories that pour out smoke to hide even the sky.
Have a look around you.
What have we done to nature?
T30, one continuous city from Marseille to Genoa, from Paris to Le Havre.
The Valley of the Rhine, one city.
Holland, one city.
All of southern England, one city.
From Tokyo to Kyoto, one city of 100 million inhabitants.
No more forests, no more trees, all cut down.
The land is barren.
The Earth was forming.
In the beginning, there was chaos.
Many years later, the Earth contained 1 million inhabitants,
who were barely beginning to walk upright.
25,000 years ago, there were 3 million Cro-Magnons.
In the year zero, there were 250 million inhabitants.
In 1500, 450 million.
From year 0 to 1500, in 1500 years, the global population had not quite doubled.
Now it is going to double in 350 years.
Then in 100 years.
Then in 35 years, in one generation.
Year 2010, 7 billion inhabitants.
Year 2040, 14 billion.
Year 2070, 28 billion.
The birth rate is down in the developed countries.
But at the conference in Bucharest in 1974, the heads of state of the third world countries would not accept demographical restrictions.
For isn't prestige and power commensurate with number?
It takes time.
All those centuries of organic activity took the Earth five billion years.
Proper living conditions for man.
In 100 years and 50 million times less time, man is about to destroy it all.
A lack of foresight, lack of wisdom, in less than one little century.
To examine our situation, our reserves of raw materials first.
It may not work, Mr. President.
Now look at the graphs in our computers.
Results are all catastrophic in every sector.
Resources show continuous laws.
We're now far under the crisis level.
Our system's economically on its way to bankruptcy.
And you'll continue to say that all goes well, gentlemen.
What have you got to say to that?
All the computers are at fault in our work.
It's on the verge of all being crowned with success.
And now more problems.
As long as the experts are here,
But it works very well. It works very well. It works very well. It works very well.
They must renounce their hostile conduct yourself as a consequence, don't you?
The situation looks bad. Verify the state of our stocks, Mr. X-Burks.
Our resources are almost exhausted. What do you think?
No, it's okay. It's okay. Everything's fine. Everything's fine. Everything's fine.
I'm going to make a speech. All our difficulties are caused by our enemies as usual.
The squares, and they must surrender or suffer the consequences. Do you understand?
If only our two neighbors to the north would wipe each other out, that would help us to settle this. They're not too brilliant.
I've an idea, sir. To help us keep our nation busy, why don't we make them push all our garbage next door? Not a bad idea, huh?
Yeah, yeah, it's a great idea.
Population Bicon. I decree a mass conscription of this land to liberate our national territory and to push all our garbage back into our neighbor's territory. Now let's go.
Good Bicons. Courage, you will conquer.
Yes.
The bygones are bringing their garbage!
The situation is bad, president.
Let's try to push all of their garbage right back into their territory.
Situation is very bad, president.
Let's try to push them and their garbage right back into their territory.
I've got another idea.
You better forget your idea.
That's a great idea.
Huh?
Oh, hehehehe.
We've got to eat it.
That's an idea.
A weebomb here for the squares, and so they don't get jealous, a weebomb for the rounds.
Once you're really a genius, they'll think each of the others set off the attack and then be exterminated mutually, you see?
And then we shall be rulers of the world to do it!
Hooray! Hooray!
Work quickly, okay?
Hey, sir, all ready.
Since the beginning of time, man was inclined to fight to the finish.
To do this, nothing seemed better than an argument.
A forceful one.
Survival in the law of the jungle.
Competition.
Relief from boredom.
Whatever the reasons, over the centuries, technology evolved and perfected itself.
Work on a small scale diminished.
and then disappeared, giving way to conglomerate.
And even though mentality remained Cro-Magnon,
perfection of technology was having a boom.
Strongest.
Decades now, more than 60 nations on this planet
have the atomic bomb.
Then, only the men who were out in space
at the time of the explosion survived it.
Fortunately, they were among the men and women
who understood that the only way of saving mankind
from extinction was through men of science and thinkers.
Some military, too.
The power of attention of giving in.
That is true.
High time to do some serious work now.
On the great satellite entrance, there was founded a communal nation.
White, yellow, black, square, round, one single human family.
Technology and resources were open to all.
Everything was run on an unlimited source of solar energy.
The council will examine today all our capacities for producing nutrition and energy here.
At this point of balance, we have limited our number of births and our number of deaths, and we're waiting.
What are we waiting for?
For the Earth to decontaminate itself and become habitable again for man.
Our mission today is to measure the level of radioactivity.
But you know all that very well, my dear.
Well, do you think it'll last much longer?
Hmm. Look at this.
You can see there's still too much strontium-90.
There's enough for several decades still.
That's far off, and lengthening the life of humans is hardly progressing.
At any rate, we've begun hibernating many among us,
and we're looking for planets to live on.
Maestro thinks that we're on the right road now.
Are you all ready now?
I'm trying to be more responsible than the last time.
There's Jumbo, look at him go.
Good luck, darling, careful.
That's Jumbo, always on the lookout for his plan.
Time to go home now, our mission is accomplished.
This vision of the future may appear overly pessimistic,
but you see, perhaps this is the only way we've got to alert our descendants.
If all of us, men and women of today, would only pay full attention,
if we're not watchful, we won't save our beautiful planet, the Earth.
Beautiful planet.
Ha, ha, ha.
Stupid, you pick up the box yourself.